microsoft came out with some news this
morning straight out of nowhere at
justin hayward gamespot news editor
please explains the folks at home and
what we know so far about this
announcement I I wouldn't say that this
was completely out of nowhere this is
something we've been conjecturing about
four months now that not only has the
xbox one gone through a hundred dollar
price cut putting it at parity with the
PlayStation 4 which it's needed to do
for a while but they've also gotten rid
of the Kinect we've said that the Kinect
is the thing that's raising the price
that that makes it a hundred dollars
more expensive and they finally just
gotten rid of it they see you know it's
surprising because they've said we're
not going to get rid of it and I thought
maybe they'll do something else to get
that price down so it's a little
surprising that they've reversed the
focus on connected and to make that the
the thing that will make the price lower
but it's not surprising in that they
needed to do something that would lower
that price and as we've seen connect
isn't terribly popular there aren't a
lot of games you know Fantasia
notwithstanding there's a kinect sports
game there's not a lot of other there's
not a lot of other games that use Kinect
that make it an integral part of it so
if you're going to cut anything I mean
that's that's one of the things that has
to go so what is the price point now
what are we talking right now it is a
399 dollar machine you can still get a
connected is still a standalone thing
they haven't announced a price for that
but you know probably gonna guess about
a about a hundred dollars yeah cuz
that's oh that's how much they've
reversed it is the old bundle of 499 for
xbox one with Kinect still happening are
they just replacing that sku with the
one I mean this this is good news
because it's giving people choices if
you want the kinect right now you can
still get the context box one they offer
right now with the kinect bundle then or
you can get the 399 volar version with
no connect yeah so it's a smart move
it's something that they've needed to do
but it's definitely not great for
probably some developers who have put a
lot of time and effort into into these
kinect games but i do you guys play
anything on connect that's the thing i
was always pondering about this earlier
on and it's also may be worth mentioning
briefly as well that em it's gone down
to 350 pounds in the UK which is a
substantially less price drop it's only
50 quid and so like I think an
equivalent dollars it's still like a
thousand dollars
it's outrageous and also I believe this
isn't coming to Ireland Jeff because
that's in the eurozone and but I was
thinking about this this morning the air
I have always wanted that one good
Kinect games kamesh I feel like during
the 360 I was thinking the same thing I
was like one game that'll be worth
that'll make it this thing worthwhile a
little kick off I was kind of happy when
they brought at the xbox one version
they made it stand standardized because
I thought it's gonna be quite cool
because now people are going to be
encouraged to make good Kinect games yes
it's never happened and model I mean how
is an alignment they done some work with
it you know what games are even out for
Kinect now you've got kinect sports
rivals which there's like one or two
decent games in there but then the rest
of it I mean the most of the emphasis on
connect at this point I feel like has
been you I management yeah I mean that's
part do this thing and even that is like
eighty percent for me and I have to use
a stern voice that my wife hates so I
don't use it oh and also that's fixing a
problem with the UI that shouldn't
really exist in the first place it's
only better to use it with the voice
because that interface is actually kind
of a mess like the whole my games and
apps thing on but it's really nice to be
able to turn your xbox on just by like
speaking to it like that is cooled like
whenever I use something like that it
feels like the future and then when it
does work like that still also feels
like a trap your xbox Netflix and I just
go it does exactly what you want to do
but like you said it doesn't work quite
enough and the things that it adds two
games are are these small add-on says
it's not a you can't use a full-featured
again you can't have a game that's only
movement because that's tiring like when
we when you play games we want to sit
down on the couch you want to relax for
a bit so having a game that only uses
connect is tiring we really get into it
let me to commit to a dance central
which are excellent Kinect games yeah I
need to commit to a gun stringer which
is actually like waiting but less of a
physical investment than dance central
because you can sit there yeah because
you can do that thing and that game was
really good but I guess my big question
with this is why in the middle of May do
they announce this so that's that's the
other really interesting thing about
this this is an e3 level announcement
like this is a bombshell the right kind
of thing that you just come out like 100
dollar price drop the fact that they're
doing this in May is basically saying we
are so confident in what
we have lined up for e3 we're going to
make this all it like seriously we're
making this about the games we've
already talked about TV and shows we
push that out of the way they've talked
about the console and the price point
push that out of the way and that's
going to make III about the games it
could also be a damage limitation name
because no matter what they talked about
at e3 even if they announced wonderful
on the next games and nobody knows about
the narrative was always going to be
connect is gone especially if they don't
answer to d3 especially considering what
happened last year and maybe they don't
want the second d three in a row to be
the story being that Microsoft of you
know the story how they reverse to this
thing and went back on that thing and
change their plan that they had
previously tried too hard Selma's but
but it's nice that it is going to have a
focus on on the games I mean we're going
to talk about playstation 4 and xbox one
games we're not going to be discussing
some kind of thing about the hardware or
anything like that like that's going to
make III really about the games and from
Nintendo's point of view as well like
we're probably going to hear something
about their quality of life stuff
because they've been talking about that
for such a long time but for them as
well it's going to be about the games
and nets that makes III itself like so
much fun that's like this is the e3
that's all about games you haven't heard
of before and you know sequels to games
that we've been anticipating for such a
long time here's hoping I got some
questions asked some folks on Twitter
and earlier today what the people who
owned Xbox one's what they what they
felt about it at Craig Sutherland said
happy and sad it's too bad that this
pretty much means that the Kinect is
dead but it could also help the x1 xbox
one to succeed in the long run do you
think this is basically the death knell
of connect that when people are given
the option that i'd retail they're going
to opt for the cheaper woman at the the
funny camera well yeah I'm they're going
to go for the cheaper one this this puts
the impetus on Microsoft to create
experiences for the kinect to make it to
make it have a long life yeah I mean
really the Kinect hasn't had much of a
life before hand we've had connect with
xbox 360 and outside of you know the
really cool music experiences like dance
central I never use it Microsoft the the
fitness game nike+ nike fitness could
apply whatever like that was also really
good those are the only two games that i
can think of that i loved having connect
for gun stringer was new but we've got a
big proponent of the UFC fighting
fitness game as well but i feel like the
problem with kinect now is the same
problem had before right it's a
peripheral so you need to justify that
big extra
expense why are people going to buy it
when it was bundled in with the xbox one
people like I had it now I was like sure
I'll give voice commands a try I'm not
going to buy it for voice commands I'm
gonna buy it if there's a game if
there's a compelling reason you know
maybe i would buy for skype but then i
have like a laptop with a camera in it
so you know I use it for skype but those
sort of add-on benefits i think it's
going to be tough for them to message
how those little things are part of the
kinect value proposition and it put you
they need something bigger they're going
to need to like bundle it with fantasia
or with something else in order to
really help people get over that extra
hump of spending that extra hundred
dollars now I wonder if that's something
we might hear about at e3 then and in
that case you know speaking about skype
we also learned that that's going to be
part of everybody's experience on xbox
now you don't have to pay for gold in
order to access things like skype in
order to access things like Netflix in
those movie applications which before
we're we're trapped behind that pay wall
when you made it just such a ridiculous
proposition to pay extra for gold when
this is something that you can get for
free on everything on your computer on
your Playstation 4 yeah sometimes on
your TV and is actually the reason the
iPlayer for BBC had such a hard time
getting on as well because they legally
weren't allowed charge for that service
at all um does some other information in
relation out stuff as well tertiary
stuff like for instance the free games
on the 360 is going to come to xbox one
and you which we knew was going to
happen like and just finally confirming
this is going to happen like no
seriously guys we're doing it and for
the anniversary of why games with gold
you're going to have three games coming
in june which is kind of cool for people
that have been investing in it for quite
a while they haven't announced the game
specifically right I think L know he had
dark souls Charlie murdered and one of
the game which is escaping my okay I saw
max the Chris Brotherhood and halo next
Chris Korell yeah maybe halo Spartan
assault as well and last point and this
is I think very sailing when I saw on
Twitter earlier as well at the weave 24
said it's a bad idea by Microsoft Kinect
is the only thing that makes the console
decent different what if Xbox drops at
the price further in the ps4 has
microsoft basically made itself so
homogenized by taking all the stuff that
they went on about last year 83
they've reversed essentially on all the
fundamentally important ones have they
just made it so that they are they've
given people no reason they're to choose
between the 2i I wouldn't really say
that's the case like the PlayStation 4
and the Xbox just bind themselves offer
two very different UI experiences like
when the one of the things that you know
Xbox offers is the ability to switch
between applications like sliding having
two things running at the same time
which PlayStation doesn't quite do as
well and then some people prefer the
twitch experience on xbox one over
PlayStation 4 and the movie experiences
i found that netflix is very different
between ps4 and xbox one I actually just
prefer using my TV yes that's a lot
quicker and easier but I I wouldn't say
that there that that's similar
especially when you compare to the pc i
mean the the games architecture the way
that we experience games is really
homogenized between everything we get
this very similar experiences and this
could really push Microsoft to try to
get more exclusives in the same way that
that Sony is known for games like semi
you know Sony Santa Monica having last
of us and God of War like I think this
will only push Microsoft to push to put
even more into those exclusives they get
games that you're not going to be able
to get anyplace else because do you
really need like a completely different
way of interacting with that console
like why is that the thing that needs to
set it apart we want the things that set
it apart to be the games and I mean you
can't forget that we also have the xbox
live entertainment services like they're
going to be rolling out these new news
and not news they're gonna be rolling
out these the halo TV show and they have
a comedy program and some other just
original program and that comedy program
won't be very funny putting money on it
right now Louie CK Sarah Silverman were
involved in it i is pretty good yeah
that it your money's already dead down
as soon as they said though glee have a
comedy program is like that's gonna suck
and then Sarah Silverman came on and
Louie CK was like oh that might not suck
all right we'll have to wait and see
Justin hey well thank you very much for
coming on thanks for letting whole bunch
of mesfet connect